vers vous bruno daroux on s'en prend
maintenant dureau du coup directement un
sergueï lavrov le chef de la diplomatie
russe et vladimir poutine le chef du
kremlin des sanctions ont été décidées
oui et surtout vladimir poutine
évidemment le symbole est très fort on
sait que hier quand joe biden a pris la
parole on attendait à ce que les états
unis prennent aussi des mesures
directement contre la personne et la
fortune de vladimir poutine joe biden ne
l'a pas fait ça a été critiqué et là
pour le coup les européens sont un peu
en avance par rapport aux états unis est
évidemment symbole très fort vladimir
poutine directement visé je crois que
c'est une des premières fois qu'un chef
d'état en exercice est visé par des
sanctions financières et puis évidemment
sergueï lavrov le ministre
l'inamovible ministre des affaires
étrangères qui lui aussi est visé alors
concernant la fortune de vladimir
poutine qui est immense a selon le
magazine forbes la fortune de l'admirent
poutine est estimé à 200 milliards
d'euros ou de dollars enfin peu importe
ce niveau là donc c'est très riche un
c'est quasiment cessé depuis % du pib
français rien pour monsieur vladimir
poutine donc c'est une fortune énorme
après la difficulté c'est de repérer là
où elle se cache si je puis dire dans
les sociétés offshore et puis il ya tout
un tas de procédure puisque nous nous
sommes des états de droit donc on ne
prend pas des sanctions comme ça contre
les possessions financière d'un individu
mais le symbole là franchement et marqué
après ce que disait alice on sent qu'il
ya un débat sur l'ampleur des sanctions
je vous disais tout à l'heure que
françois hollande rift n'est toujours
pas dû voir comment ça en fait ça se
crispe notamment en retour de de ce
système swift françois hollande ce matin
disait qu'il estimait que les sanctions
prises par les américains et européens
n'étaient pas assez fortes passé massive
et il ya notamment effectivement la
question de ce système swift qui est
donc le système de compensation
internationale qui permet à toutes les
banques 1,2 de faire des transactions
entre elles et aux états aussi de payer
bas notamment le gaz ou le pétrole
en dollars c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs des
pays comme l'allemagne et l'italie qui
sont très dépendants du gaz russe en
l'occurrence l'allemagne c'est quand
même une dépendance à hauteur de 55%
c'est pour ça que la entre les européens
visiblement il n'y a pas encore
consensus pour prendre cette mesure qui
serait très forte mais mesure que n'a
pas prise non plus washington joe biden
hier soir n'a pas annoncé de deux
mesures concernant le système fut ce qui
est quand même dominé par les états unis
merci bruno daroux